[موسيقى]
اسمي أليس هولمان وأنا أعزف تينور
سميث-كورونا مع أوركسترا الآلة الكاتبة في بوسطن ،
وأوركسترا بوسطن بايبر 2
هي مجموعة لفاتورة الآلة الكاتبة ،
وبعضنا لديه خلفيات موسيقية ،
والبعض منا لا يلعبه العديد من أعضائنا
في فرق  حاليًا لم أتطرق
إلى أي شيء باستثناء الآلات الكاتبة
منذ لعب الترومبون في
المدرسة الثانوية ، فنحن نلعب مجموعة متنوعة من
الآلات الكاتبة من بعض الطرز المحمولة الصغيرة
وصولاً إلى بعض
طرز المكاتب الكبيرة نسبيًا ، الكثير مما نفعله في
البناء  تستكشف الأغاني
حقًا الأصوات المختلفة التي يمكننا إخراجها
من الآلة الكاتبة وكيف يمكننا
دمجها في أغنية على سبيل المثال ،
لديك المفتاح الذي يجعله من F
صوت طقطقة أساسي ولكن بعد ذلك يكون
لديك التحول الذي يتحرك كثيرًا
الميكانيكا وتصنع صوتًا جهيرًا إلى حد ما ، ثم
لديك أيضًا الأسطوانة التي
تحصل على نوع من صوت السقاطة الميكانيكية
كما يوحي اسمها بأن
الآلة الكاتبة بوسطن أوركسترا هي بوسطن.
لقد لعبنا بالفعل في جميع أنحاء نيو
إنجلاند ،
معظم الآلات الكاتبة تبلغ من العمر 50 60 و 70
عامًا ، وعادة في أيدينا ، نرى من
سنتين إلى ثلاث سنوات من العمر
نتغذى عليها بشدة عندما بدأنا
في عام 2004 كنا  مجموعة من الرجال
يجتمعون ويضربون على
الآلات الكاتبة نوعًا ما نحصل على أننا
غريبون نوعًا ما ، إنها فكرة غريبة بعض الشيء ،
لكننا اكتشفنا أن هذا يجعل
بعض الموسيقى المشروعة وأنت تعلم أنه
يمكن أن يكون مسعى حقيقيًا جادًا  لدينا
أغانٍ حقيقية تتحد معًا
ويبدو أن الناس يستمتعون بها حقًا وطالما
أننا ما زلنا نستمتع بالناس ،
سنبقى بالخارج
ونكتب لك [تصفيق]